okay for people who are joining this
live stream we are talking about food in
wolf alpha and wolf language and let's
see it's been a while since I've seen
what we're doing here big project and
what should I be doing so like all the
last year's we have leave em to whole
food and in the language we have it a
viable sense how much of your plus and
does is now the new pull from alpha
website the new pods and everything
based on great partly because they does
it how much bigger is the later sir I
believe the previous version had about
like 12,000 foods and we have about 15
I'm sorry 150,000 foods almost now okay
and for example if I'm okay so can I do
this what where am I going under under
current or what should I do
so there there are links to current as
well but if you intend to test it on go
on go to current on a web browser you
can but I think it's probably easier to
use the links in the notebook further
down once we've talked about some of the
changes are there are some hyperlinks
that you can click on that will take you
to current okay but I mean if I if I'm
to looking if I want to go just just
check out some new foods and things can
I do that on um if I just go to current
can I like yes yeah you can but you'll
need the prefix owl mode that's because
it's only in the Wolfram language at the
moment and is not exposed so if I say
for example orange trust chocolate well
I'd be in luck or will I not be in luck
here I'm not looking promising okay
so would you expect it okay that's cool
that we have that okay so they're gonna
be new pods yeah these are these are
these the old pots are these new pots
yeah that looks like it did not parse
correctly in the new stuff and so it
used the old existing one okay so what
would I do to make it make it um I think
we may not have that in the new stuff
yet or at least not the complete
linguistics for it okay all right okay
perhaps the different would be fettered
fine so let's actually look through here
okay example foods they thought that
this is what you wanted unchanged it
since the last time so that's the first
second okay so the example foods are
split into generic and Bend
oh so with this this just went okay so
if I say I'll mode and I get a picture
of an owl um saltines oh gosh well
that's bad parse as you can see right
there are a few issues with the parsing
particularly since we haven't fully
switched over to the new system which I
mean but that parse but but obviously
anything that is in fact a food that's
in word data should be picked up here
right so now there's several issues here
that I can see immediately I mean so
first of all bat is really ugly
and then the fonts are bad the size is
wrong etc right yes that's a recent
change that we've done because it
doesn't scale well if we use the current
settings on larger screens like say on a
tablet or with magnification this isn't
gonna work so you need to find something
that will work sure right I don't know
whether this thing is an image or
whether it's it's Michael have you been
involved in this I mean this isn't yeah
this doesn't follow the standard for
what a nutrition label should look like
and it should right and and if that
needs if you need vector graphics for
that then we should be putting back to
graphics there
I don't know exactly how to do that
whether it's an SPG or what what it is
make sense
this fix it and also I thought we were
going to have an in language way of
getting nutrition labels we already do
don't we yeah okay all right so I should
stop trying to do it on the website is
what you're saying no okay but let's
take a look here okay so first of all
cracker varieties saltine okay
example foods that's a very weird thing
to say what's that but we have basically
thousands or not thousands but dozens of
food that fall under this so these are
some examples of them now I understand
that I understand that I think that
title doesn't seem like the best we're
hearing typing instances yeah I mean
specific instances that sounds a bit
technical
look instances isn't terrible I mean
this is really what what you're really
saying is this is a sub case of the
input interpretation which is something
we haven't really seen very often before
that is you know for example let's say
we have a car and it has many many many
sub right things the fact is it's still
called a car you know that particular
kind of car whereas here yeah okay
another point is about the branded ones
it's sort of unfortunate that you know a
hold is kind of winning the
lexicographic war so does being yes
and it's always going to win it then we
can sort by Sting gangs that's an
interesting idea that's an interesting
idea what about the capitalization stuff
do you have decent coverage of that I
mean in look if you were able to sort by
web frequency or something that will be
the best and coolest thing I would say
they'll be tough because it will be
tough because these names come from the
branded USDA food database whatever they
used but also providers or other
supermarkets might use a different world
order for the same product so we didn't
intend to normalize the titles he kept
them as he come from the provider now
wise like Keebler all caps is that
because that's the way that brand it
looks this he was provided by you okay
by the way the number of times I had to
press more was crazy whatever it was
doing though its mooring was needed to
be fixed
make sense yeah we can get more advanced
all right I don't understand do you mean
it was too slow or no I mean that I had
too many times in order to get this
should have been a single more to get
this amount of additional stuff probably
perhaps to Moores but in fact it was
like four or five Moore's okay it should
be doubling every time roughly okay time
out
what's that and to be potentially
timeout because for some things we have
many okay if we did string length a hold
saltine crackers wheat would win yes do
we know separately the brands which
brand it is yes we should then why not
put this as a something where there's a
brand header
I don't know what premium is that a
brand
what I'm thinking about is to have
essentially a brand header and then have
those things not necessarily stacked
like this maybe that's crazy Brent
what's that be showing one / Brent
maybe at least to show a little bit more
you know diversity of what's going on
like who has one of these things okay
you can get it from Nabisco or you can
get it from wherever just because that's
a useful piece of information a useful
piece of immediate information others a
nabisco version of this making sense I
mean yeah in fact knowing which brands
support this particular food type seems
useful to me actually more use but then
but then it like if this is useful it
seems more sensible to import like
friends that make this yes I agree
okay I mean or we could just have
something where this becomes branded and
it's a list of brands and there's a
button that says show the specifics I
feel like this is formed because we want
first you want like you asked for a food
and how we tell you a lot about pants I
suppose you say yeah I mean I agree that
it needs to be not you know front and
center there um but it's selected from
eighteen food movie if you click on the
on the button there you would see that
we have two ranges as you requested
tropane show ranges so that's
informative but non stumbled it's nice
it's nice it's really quite nice I wish
we could have it be the default because
it's actually much more you know if you
really want to know what you're eating
it's much better to be able to see that
range than to just say oh it's 11 grams
oh they actually might be 70 grams so
I'm saying then we call it something
like we preface devote Nutrition Facts
with something to make sure that's not
the standard one and sure so boost by
default would be one possibility I think
that's a serious possibility all
is really useful to me I mean I don't
know what people who are more food
oriented think but you know it seems
like really useful to me to know okay
the carbs for this it doesn't really
matter which brand I have the carbs or
was gonna be about the same making sense
whereas the sodium is way different now
I like it but it might not be
everybody's interest okay is it okay so
I think we should show both of them is
there any possibility could we show them
next to each other
I don't think so we have I think over
the now does under smaller ones
makes us out of space okay fine they
could be just in the same pod but
different sub pods one could be yeah I
understand on and ranged the other
possibility would be you know this stuff
down here is probably less important I
mean you know people are gonna make look
I suspect what do I know about the stuff
I mean sodium and carbs people pay
attention to I think yes that's right
they out there and I know that's why
they're in the label I'm saying that we
could have a secondary label which which
by default doesn't show the whole thing
to do save to four lands at the bottom
that's a waste of time I think they do
that's the thing that bothers me is that
the average nutrition label is cute but
fake
in a sense we don't know how to do the
average what does average mean you know
across a measure based on grocery stores
or something you know what I'm saying I
think it mean yeah I think you very to
remember Andrew correct me it means what
the USDA determines based on their
Center sites plus 20 percent or 15
percent a measurement error you know
really based on so they bought saltine
crackers based on this is so so intimate
so did they buy an equal number of
Nabisco and Keebler saltine crackers or
did they buy them in ratio but people
buy them in actual soup no definitely
not pretty sure not I don't think it is
so detailed I mean when you go to the
USDA food database but your food they
only show you the numbers but you can
get means and standard deviations and
these things okay but we need how many
but I doubt it is weighted by okay let's
figure that out let's find out how real
the average is
I think that's gonna determine what we
really want to do with this so this is
very questionable because for an
individual it does not matter what what
people consume what do you mean okay
like you wanted to vary the weighting
you wanted according to how many of them
is all day modular table stupid because
your actual neighborhood grocery store
might only sell it is my point so I feel
like uniform sampling is better nice
yeah okay a same thing based on usage no
no Michael because the chance that
you're right right if if if only one
store in the country sells premium
saltine crackers right then the
probability of you I mean it's a weird
calculus here I mean the probability of
you being right it's much higher if it's
weighted by what I'm saying yeah but I
think it would be unrealistic to get the
distribution well that may be true but
but the question of what one should do
yeah
well I understand I let's let's loop
back to this I want to see a bunch more
stuff I really like this Rangers thing
though and Jorge on our livestream is
also supporting me that he thinks the
Rangers good too
I agree um people are more used to not
the Rangers I am aware I know where so
both have a value okay and the only
question is whether we want to use the
real estate to show them both no there's
probably too much
because you want to show the pictures
you know that's just
nutrition labels I would disagree with
this one because I feel like to pick
yourself basically civil informational
there you yeah the pictures are
entertaining and they mostly are did I
buy the right thing is this no not did I
buy the right thing is this talking
about the thing that I'm holding in my
hand
I mean honestly they're more in the
input interpretation area in a sense
okay but let's talk about the image of
things selected from 18 foods what on
earth does that mean there are 18 foods
are Mars that's matched and have images
I believes what that means okay but then
I think what we want to say is whatever
that this is instances up here and then
I think what we should say is sample
images here and then just a dot dot dot
paren 18 total and then with a more
button that's what I think and this is
not oh yeah does say it will be nice if
this font could be smaller here those
labels they're very they're very you
know you know it's like it's just
reminding you I mean really okay also
does the picture what happens to the
picture oh cool magnificent okay what
the heck is this double stool such as
well it looks very interesting but what
is it
the properties and and and run feature
space pose over them no I understand
what's the category of thing that's in
the feature space plot that's actually a
good question that's what I wanted to
that's one of the questions I put in the
notebook um that's one thing I noticed
in preparing for all this stuff is that
it's it's really cool and looks neat but
yes it needs to probably say well like
where is saltines in this whole thing
right so normally if the the way this
works is that those foods that had
enough data to make it into the plot are
shown in there so that's all crackers if
saltine crackers wound up in this plot
they are highlighted in red they didn't
seem to make it in this one so saltine
crackers must not have enough
information to have made it for the data
that I had to set up with but if you
look in the notebook mother
or some examples there where I'm where
the dots are actually lit up in red for
the ones that match okay basically it's
a little bit zooming out it's not kind
of which of this chaos should I buy but
yeah I mean it's pretty interesting that
they're basically it's saying that this
is an outlier whatever this is whole
wheat crackers are an outlier from all
these other ones this needs more work to
figure out both the labeling and the I
mean by the way that size of labeling
could really be used here I think
without harm to notable features that's
a very weird part of speech for for what
is that what we did before had we not
had this one before please
food-type this is very awkward English
if I might say so did we have we had a
pod like this before no this is new okay
so what this really is is saltine
crackers are a good source of manganese
that's what you're basically saying
right yes yeah there's not so
interesting most people are interested
in iron ore 40s it or something like
that I think I mean but if you you know
I have never heard of anybody said to
have a manganese no well why not
I mean maybe people have manganese
deficiencies and they don't know it and
that's what causes some terrible disease
lots of people have who knows okay in
any case is it the case that when you
say notable features what other possible
notable features are there are they all
good source of or are they something
different I think they're all variations
on good source high source ma I think
that is because then then what I think
is that we want to say something that we
want to have the pod title be something
like you know more more like the good
source of although that's not quite the
English construction we use okay that's
better that's better part of speech but
the good thoughts was the taking it home
yeah
yes USDA I believe on my FDA rather
Armada finds one the ranges for
something to be considered a good source
a great source you know okay fine fine
but but then then let's just say look
good source of nutrients doesn't work
right I mean better would be to have
notable features don't box it have this
just say good source of : you know in
slight gray :
manganese you know great source of : you
know molybdenum or something I'm making
sense
fine option might be to lump in dietary
restrictions once that is prepared we
could put that as a notable feature as
well an example of one of those like
gluten-free vegan vegetarian yes that
would be interesting I agree that's a
possible thing to put in there as well
hmm
that plot is too big see I'm right I
mean it just it should just be half the
size because it just doesn't have that
much information content nice plot am I
making sense yep um yeah literally just
half the size because it's gonna work
fine at half the size isn't it that's
never for nothing is it this is the
level of detail that any of these are
going to get right it may be even less
than half the size okay okay so I'm
suggesting take that and 180 times 180
honestly we'd be fine at that size
because all you're getting is the shape
and you're saying does it point at carbs
I mean obviously the carbs protein etc
that the sizes of those are roughly
right see what I'm saying ya think it's
fine that kind of size so 1:40 that was
actually smaller that was 120 something
you know you'll have to thicken up some
pieces and things but I think that's the
right thing um that's interesting
okay energy content
um there's a lot of new stuff it's great
okay highest daily recommended values
okay I understand what you're trying to
say I think it's poorly said you're
saying these are the things of which
this food gives and by the way I don't
even know whether it's the average here
what happened here what happened here
with your averaging why isn't there a
picture like that in other words when
we've got this ranging stuff going on up
above why isn't this ranged as well
I think it's too complicated well what
about the possibility of opacity look
what you're showing here I don't think
that's hopeless what you're showing here
is I mean look there are values here
imagine that you could have opacity
showing the range imagine that what you
had was the outer boundary and what
you're gonna get is two different things
I guess they can cross over no they
cannot cross over because they're both
bounded ranges right so you've got two
polytopes one inside the other
no I don't see why there's no reason to
it today David cause over another one if
one is saying that it could be the case
that but-but-but I mean the only thing
that's meaningful here is the values on
the coordinate directions right yes
so isn't every coordinate Direction like
the protein is blah blah right
okay this depends I fancy it if one sees
it for each min Max or if one sees for
each concrete food food has a polytope
tend to put it up to view all having
exactly both are interesting it seems to
me I think the default should be the men
Max of each side BM but then it will be
cool if we can do it to be able to plot
the thing for all foods superimposed
somehow I think you for the normals no
but we can try it try it is this great
data Georgia on a live stream is
pointing out that in Europe these things
are measured in joules I assume we
localize
it's just let's just for the hell of it
let's check if we don't we certainly can
put that in I wouldn't want to say we
want to say all mode plus plus IP equals
dot F R for example we don't we should
yep yeah that can be fixed check which
countries it's in thank you George
okay let's go to this one now umm this
naming is just utterly confusing also
the bars are too thick in my view the
bars just need I mean you don't need a
great big you know tall yellow bar you
could just do with a straight um you
know a straight just lying out there
pretty much making sense okay by the way
the great not to hear your mouse wheel
sir um okay so I would say this should
say something like top
since what is the top what are these
things called components what what are
they called what what is selenium is a
bla of a cracker and nutrients
these are nutrients okay whoo that's
hard to say then it's also important to
note that these are only the nutrients
that have daily values daily recommended
values defined like there could be some
fish wouldn't even show up so right this
is so in
I mean if maybe top will be better than
highest top daily recommended values
what about highest in this clarify what
would be the full full form highest by
any recommended values no it's in
comprehensive okay how about daily
recommended values highest for this food
that's stupid - gosh I don't know
all right let's come back
faction of today's recommended values no
what does that mean that's a fraction of
daily but that's largest but what is the
largest qualify direction I understand
but it's not obvious it qualifies the
fraction it could qualify the value yes
yeah that's good
then we add parents what to make sure
who is qualified okay let's think if we
have multiple foods what would this part
look like
doesn't have comparison limit at the
moment I do not believe so I think this
only happens for single entities might
be interesting that to have you know to
have bars out of both for both foods
sorted by the highest in either food if
you understand what I'm saying and then
you can compare like one of them is you
know in other words if you get what I'm
saying but highest and either food and
then um I can see how you wound up
saying highlights highest daily
recommended values it is however
incomprehensible when you first see it
see the problem is when you say energy
it's clear that's energy content of the
food here their daily recommended values
the sensitive daily recommended value
it's obvious that it's ranked by
magnitude you know but particularly if
we put a dot dot dot at the bottom yeah
well I was wondering what about saying
something like highest nutrient density
values because I think that's
essentially it's measuring the amount of
nutrients per serving and so if you have
more of a particular nutrient for a
certain amount of food whether it's a
weight or a volume then it's higher and
nutrient density so I think that's
essentially what this is saying is that
you know it's dense in these nutrients
well it's interesting
I mean that's nice because it explains
what's going on particularly if it's
correct
well so what you're suggesting is
highest densities highest I think people
will think critical density yeah and the
Center for a child I don't know a
solution for this yet we have to come
back to it I don't know what the heck is
approximate approximate is a term that's
used to describe the basic nutrients
that people typically care about the big
ones that are on the label so the ones
you see they're carbs fats protein and
so on those are called proc Smiths we
can't use that tub no no a mature person
is going to know what that means I would
say
basic nutrient information and then
we could cotton macro-nutrients that's
correct that would be fine except as
water isn't a nutrient last I knew and
why is this timing out that's amusing I
would have thought that we wanted to
what how are we sorting those particular
activities I'm not sure at the moment
but we can rearrange it if needed well I
mean they just seem totally random what
about walking what about running what
about you know why are we picking these
particular ones am I making sense yes
possibly because we didn't want to over
emphasize this right I know but I mean
this these particular collections seem
really random to me and aren't they
ranked by I mean if I understand it
calories you know bicycling sewing
whatever you burn calories at a certain
rate it's not like it matters whether
the calories come from cabbage or
chocolate correct yes
so to me I mean what you're showing here
boy
I mean this is a really weird list if I
might say so I mean walking isn't it
isn't among them for example to be
honest with you on my the where this
data comes from is rather oddly specific
there are some things like I think the
bicycling one is like technically taken
from data for bicycling to work there
are some that are like sitting on a
couch things like just walking yeah and
you know I mean also this is kind of
crazy six point four minutes okay well
it depends on whether I do does anybody
even say calisthenics anymore I thought
that was a 1960s word but but seriously
six point four minutes is too much
precision yeah I think one digit is
really all you're gonna get from these
things well I mean these 13 is okay I
admit this sort of one and a half digits
but you know 194 is really really
specific like it's like I just got
myself a Bluetooth connected toothbrush
which records precisely that I should
spend two minutes brushing my teeth and
do you know which two you touched on no
it knows the pressure there is there is
some technology that gives you that but
I don't think it's really ready for
primetime we've talked to a number of
companies that have various in mouth
camera thingies but yeah I mean it don't
think it even knows you know it could
have accelerometers that know which way
up it isn't think it knows that could
indeed not just have if you have your
bluetooth set on the ER measure
distances
well yeah it's an interesting idea I
don't think you need I mean look it can
also measure whether the toothbrush is
you know what the orientation of the
toothbrush is right which like the
stapes yeah which would certain give
some information and it should be able
to measure I mean it should be able to
measure from accelerometer data anyway
never mind we're not we're not doing
connected toothbrushes right now we're
we're um okay let's go
go ahead more content to go through if
you I know I know I know so don't get me
distracted talking about connecting
toothbrushes okay what is this food type
image so this says just a 1 an ethyl you
don't want to see pictures of epic ships
or something it always shows in the
middle of an apple that was one thing we
discussed in our previous meeting is
that if you punch in an apple and you
find liked images below where it only
shows slices you may want to know what
an actual apple looks like and that's
what this image that pod serves if I if
if what I specified here was his
applesauce or something am I still gonna
see an apple here or does it just really
going to just be applesauce well you'll
get both right because um the images
part will show you the specific ones
that match your query and then the food
type one will still show up to remind
you what an apple looks like for example
if okay so type is basically but let it
up okay but by food type you mean the
thing from which this was derived by
squashing baking slicing whatever else
yes more or less yes who typed in foods
right but I mean really what it's what
the content of the what went in the raw
material for these things hundred pounds
of cheese you don't want to see what for
oh geez is what you're saying you're
showing this is you know food type is
really a weird thing for me for that
name for you know
given that it's the Apple which is going
to be turned into a lot of prepackaged
foods I can take generic in collagen
Eric well really isn't it
food content food
food content image I don't know that's
not quite right either I could always be
correct yes well let's find out what
some of the other examples are by the
way George on the live stream is
agreeing with me that that these things
can't really be stated to more than a
digit yeah the precision this will be
George at the live stream I don't know
George has been active and we appreciate
his comments and okay so I'm not happy
with this but I don't know what to do
with it exactly I mean I think it's
confusing when you ask for applesauce
you get a picture of an apple I mean
that's kind of stupid cuz we all know
what an apple looks like if you asked
for I don't know some what would be an
example where this is really useful
unusual tropical fruits a lot of people
don't know what a durian looks like
looks like during it's a notorious fruit
that's common in Southeast Asia that's
illegal to eat in the public in
Singapore because it's so smelly it
smells like rotten flesh and then
attracts flies d u d-- u d-- u r i8 okay
so i go to food type here so i don't
understand any of this what the heck is
root results here
that doesn't make any sense the only one
now what is result mean yes you have to
change that I think that's I think a pod
may have timed out or something I think
normally it replaces it with a different
result there with the example Foods
thing okay fine so that will be
instances or instance but that's pretty
weird when there's only one of it well
okay so maybe what it wants to say
something like specific instances and
this would be the singer or specific
instance not making sense okay so here
if there's only one of it again we just
say image presumably or maybe not I I
don't know in this case so one one
example where the image may be useful ma
is if you qualify on a food for example
a Red Delicious apple or maybe a granny
smith apple for example we have images
for lots of those you expect to see a
green one but if you may be nice be nice
to know what a generic apple looks like
and that's when you would get it also an
image of a specific apple or in the case
of like the screenshot on the left there
if you looked up apple slices for
example you would get pictures of the
products for apple slices but you may
also want to know what an apple looks
like that's really I think the goal of
that pot yes I agree I understand
understand I mean I think there are many
corner cases that we're seeing in this
thing on the right that are not being
well handled with the current oh that's
interesting that was a part we didn't
see in the other case yes I think so
because we know this is a category of
thing no but we would have known in
another case it was a category thing of
crackers right but crackers don't
exactly fit into the categories that we
have good data on to create that pod I
see so this is some kind of fairly
complete collection of fruits
that the idea yes so the fruits
correspond to one of the five basic food
groups that I believe the USDA defines
in my plate okay
and again there's this issue of of
metric of measures so to speak it's it's
one fruit for itself so to speak you
know one fruit one unit type thing I
think that pod makes a little more sense
if you look in the notebook if we use
we'll scroll down a little bit you'll
see more examples of what it's typically
looks like in in more cases where
there's more data let's take a look at
no and there's also that a feature space
plot too or you could see where it's lit
up in red that's pretty cool okay so
look in terms of labeling here having
some labeling for the outlines will be
very useful if we can arrange that I
mean yeah when there when there are
hundreds of points it gets very
difficult to have labeling with who
asked asked between Bret and again and
so on
ask him what can be done I mean show
them these examples because what do you
learn from this okay what you really
learn is what what are you trying to
learn what you're trying to learn is
what matters and what doesn't right
for instance
in this corner okay apples fried sulfur
done cooled that's fairly far away Gala
apples is similarly far away entering I
looked at quite a few of them and there
are some cases where I really don't
something like you have some ground beef
and you see the various amount of fat
but they're also examples where where
it's like reading tea leaves too to make
sense out of it well then let's try to
understand what we can do with that
thing to point out is that we've done
some more changes right now the feature
space plots that you're seeing now are
based only on the proximate sort those
basic nutrients that we talked about
Michael and I have a better scheme that
we've put in but it's not quite done yet
to produce slightly better ones as far
as the clustering goes you've much
better results see that's interesting
there that two different forms of white
potatoes sort of have yellow potatoes in
the middle so to speak well that's what
this is trying to give one is some sense
of you know what matters how cluster the
stuff is seems to me which if we can
give people that it seems really quite
useful
this is the example I was talking about
where you can see the food that you
queried for compared to other foods in
the same so in this case dairy so why
particular fruit invisible I know it's
done yeah I think it should be I think
there's a small bug where when you find
just one it's not showing up on the plot
it should be a doctor or a vertical bar
or something yes yes I agree I think I
think I just don't have that case
handled very well okay okay so so if you
scroll a little further down in the
notebook you'll see would help me if
this said old dairy here at cream cheese
and all dairy sure that can be done I
mean this is interesting
no question this is interesting it's
very nice actually because on a very
good sense of where the thing lies
graphically I think it doesn't need to
be as tall as this you could scrunch it
up a bit sure yeah I think
would be useful here Michael do you have
a comment on that
maybe I'm not sure I think it's just
really confusing okay because one of
them is a specific and one of them is
you know maybe discussion we saw time
that the call of dividends makes it
clear I think I agree I'm having all on
there would make it a little more clear
that it's we're talking about all dairy
items as a group rather than just dairy
I think I think you're right that's a
little misleading you know complete what
about all after theory in parens
possible that's fine too I mean I would
say all could be in gray before it will
be also fine on the live stream mapping
we useful to have all this inside both
language especially the feature space
plot it is right I can get the feature
space block on time yes the future space
plots are available at the food type
level highlighting and stuff is much
trickier how would I do it you could
just do entity value for entity so I
have is that some weird thing here to go
to the right place
no one should be on production as well
okay okay enter the value of entity food
type of entity food yes sorry the entity
is a food type maybe say Apple I could
have just done oh sorry I have a
tendency of writing it out as entity
value and then the property would be
featured space plot but can I get the
impulse that's cool and it was quite
nice and zippy - um we should talk about
what the actual exposed properties
should be because this is this is very
predigested I mean it's useful to have
the predigested thing what we also want
the input to this which is presumably a
what is the input the input to this is
presumably a bunch of vectors with
tagging
yes or no but did I feel like it's a
medium input and the input I feel like
this feature space plot for off and then
comes list of entities and poverty's you
know what you described is kind of a
medium evaluation um sorry say that
again like what you just described is
like half of the work is done but not
all then I feel like the input would be
feature space not open closed entity
where you list of foods comma list of
properties yes possibly possibly yes
although one could say here something
like we could have a qualifier that
gives you the this world possibly I
don't know I mean to me it's useful to
have the raw material for machine
learning stuff I think Michael and I
have discussed some things that we might
be able to make available that way like
a special property that gives you the
properties that were involved in the
entities and things like that but I
don't so what I would imagine is
something like the following that for
that there's essentially a data set here
for this food type that contains the
core you're calling them proximate for
example and in it what it looks like is
you know lucky leaf red spiced apple
rings whatever it is lucky leaf whatever
that entity is the lucky leaf entity
whatever um blah blah blah blah blah
arrow and then here would be you know
sodium arrow blob in other words
something which is a vector of useful
stuff that you could then go and and
process yeah we could think we could
expose that I think that would be
helpful
okay these are interesting it's a very
interesting very interesting really yeah
great
okay okay boy there's a lot to go over
here isn't there
um so this is entity property as you say
what is relative calendar the most
common clearly type we get yeah I
understand but what is the so in the
energy value why is that being singular
I mean it sounds like it's just one beam
that is the the food type there but
you're right that probably should be
switched to beans that's one of those
cases that we can switch over there are
a few cases where foods you you will say
them in plural
despite normally wanting to put the
singular in there right yeah that can be
fixed now when we say beans preparation
refried I mean how that ontological
structure so to speak I mean clearly the
in the everyday you know version of this
that we'd say refried beans but we're
thinking it's useful I mean you know
what does it look like when it gets more
complicated you mean what the
interpretation looks like when
implicated yeah I believe we've had
meetings in the past about what the
input interpretation should look like
and I think there's another example
below this okay for I think a fried
chicken leg for example and that I think
shows a little more of the detail
how can it be a whole chicken if this is
the leg of the chicken so chicken legs
are sort of countable in a sense right
there are there a whole item rather than
being a partial one and so the reason
why one item is being used there and
with the hole is that it's different
so like sliced apples for example would
not be included and that's why if you
said one Apple for example then the
slices would be excluded from the query
that's the mechanism that's that's doing
that here okay wait a minute
look the thing I'm objecting to is it's
not the whole chicken it's just the leg
of the chicken right and that's what's
the part is for okay so it's for trying
to refer to a whole leg maybe the hole
should be moved more to the right
yes I think so too oh that was
completely confusing I thought it was
the whole chicken yes yeah I think
you're right moving the hole to a
different spot when there are parts
involved it's definitely something we
should do right
I mean leg paren hole is probably what
you would want yes this is pretty
confusing I mean this is very computer
istic you know chicken amount one item
part leg preparation fried the last time
you hated more top you didn't like it
because it became pretty big I
understand but this is very computer
istic and the fact that it's you know
it's it's a you know it will be better
very you know look it's a fried chicken
leg okay
but somehow here we are you know taking
this apart and I I don't think this is
working so we should remind ourselves
what the stacked version looked like and
it may be better if we're going to have
to make it this computer istic it may be
better to give the X you know to admit
that we're being computer a stick and
stack it
it's time you didn't like this at all
just a I know I know I know
but now that I'm seeing this I don't
like this either so maybe we need a
different idea we try to be more verbose
but you didn't like that either you said
you wanna shoot movie more like this
let's let's get a bigger collection of
examples and let's let's look at this
again okay let's look at bigger set of
examples and let's for each of those
examples if you've got three ways to
present them let's present them in all
three ways and let's compare okay this
is complicated and this is this is not
gonna work people are not going to
understand this and I don't even know
what absolute iron content means I mean
it's like what is the difference in
relative calorie content when I ask for
calories an absolute iron content what
am I being told here so the difference
is in the two types of properties that
we have my inanity value so through
energy value exposure the relative ones
refer to on a per gram basis and that
way you can sort of compare them all
together almost so these are towards the
top of your notebook you can see right
now those are all in calories per gram I
see so this is because we didn't say how
many I see that's the right thing here
that decision all right it's a little
relative there I mean I would I mean I
see that if it was an absolute it would
be for one serving of refried beans is
that correct or a specific quantity yes
no I understand but I think this is
confusing because when I read this I
didn't know what it was relative to yeah
perhaps it should say calorie content
per gram to be specific but your point
may still be that it should be or
serving by default may be is that what
you're suggesting or well no I'm not
suggesting that I'm I'm suggesting
I think it might be maybe per serving is
the better default actually in which
case it could say calorie content per
serving here calorie content because as
we have seen in the example above the
serving size is very substantial okay
fine all right well then then I would
say here that the property name could be
calorie content and then gray per gram
sure and then for the absolute case we
should probably say calorie content on
its own I would think so sure
that is freaking weird but very amusing
I mean deserts just defame dog going to
work I know that I know that I know that
but the fact that the amount of iron in
a chicken leg is about the same as half
the mass of a mosquito is certainly it's
actually much more than I would have
expected but who's to know
I guess not I guess it's the amount of
blood or something and I never mind I
don't want to think about I don't
believe in foods um the uh yeah I don't
believe in knowing where foods came from
unless that just plants but that's just
me being pointed out on the livestream
that the amount that the iron it matters
a lot whether it's bioavailable or not
but we don't know that do we
no it's like the whole spinach story or
something right of weather whether you
can actually get the iron out of spinach
or not if I remember correctly well
there's not just a missing element I
don't know I thought I I thought it was
also part of the I don't know I don't
know I thought it was just a typo really
some time ago I bring but I thought it
was a typo and that's why people think
that it's a great source of iron and
it's not as great as I think people
think not that it's a terrible one I'd
if I remember correctly in spinach
you're saying yes I thought there was
like a reaction where you have a problem
with like because spinach is high in
oxalic acid or something like that that
that actually makes the iron less
available for your body to absorb so
there's certain nutrients that have
synergistic qualities where if you
consume them together you actually
absorb more of both when there's others
that have the opposite effect where
there's more what I thought what's going
on in the iron okay so yeah that's what
I recall it could be both yeah I don't
know honestly let's ask the following
question the iron that is being stated
here this is simply like
somebody put it into a mass spectrometer
and saw how many iron atoms there were
is that true I believe that is correct
so you know it is not a completely
insane point but maybe irrelevant I mean
the question of if it is the case that
there are situations with the you know
with other aspects of the food that make
the iron more or less metabolizable I
mean there might be a possible footnote
it's April Kelly's is it yes I guess
that's right it's calories from whatever
right then in principle but don't they
sometimes break that out calories from
fats and things sometimes they do but
not always like the our calories if it's
two fibers that we cannot cannot use
okay like we test plenty of calories but
it's of no use force so what do we
record when it says calories here do we
record I mean is calories based on
burning the food type thing and
therefore is it's the actual it's a
would would have a high value here I
believe that's the case
but there's there are definitions that
USDA provides and that's what we based
all of our properties on there are
specific definitions for all these
things on where it comes from and how
it's calculated and measured so the one
thing that this may highlight is you
know there are places like I don't know
you know in our tide computation thing
where we have a generic footnote that
basically says you know this is a based
on historic tide data and doesn't take
account of local storms and things the
question is would we want in a case like
this to put such a footnote in the
result that it doesn't take account of I
don't know what the right term is
whether it's bioavailability or some
other term doesn't mean yeah great it's
the same thing you know it's like the
the fact that they don't have footnotes
is it's just it's not an exact science
it's like like you asked for how much
iodine is and you didn't ask how much
iron you can't say just from it right
well fair enough but if we're going to
be helpful Michael telling people I mean
I don't know maybe people maybe the
question is this okay two things I'm
gonna pick between you know spinach and
watermelon or something I've no idea
what the iron content of watermelon is
but but doors spinach and a chicken
piece of a chicken right and I really
care about how much iron you know I
really am I'm a I'm you know I'm trying
to I'm going to high altitude I'm going
to I really need more iron ore and you
know I'm you know just the pregnancy or
whatever I don't know need more iron for
some reason right right I'm looking at
what's that mean well yes that's the
generic answer right but I mean so my
question is the the are we in fact
misleading people by saying you know we
give to iron numbers and they're
basically we give the same number let's
say for a piece of red meat and a
mysterious you know South America and
you know guava fruit or something okay
but in fact the body absorbs those by a
significantly different amount I mean is
it by 10 percent is about a factor of
two does anybody know I think that
really depends on the person's - yeah I
think that I think it may be too
complicated - but it is the effect a
factor of two effect or is it a 5%
effect
I have no idea about it I would use it
it only depends also on which element we
are talking about okay we look at the
literature bit and try and find out just
the current yet continue providing the
same information as people has if it
goes to a supermarket they they take out
the box
I'm aware I'm aware as other people have
got this wrong doesn't mean we have to
get it wrong so one thing I may offer
that we can do with the footnote is we
have definitions for these that come
from USDA we could put those as the
footnotes and say this is how it was
calculated well let's take a look at
those I don't think it's exposed
anywhere and it's in a follow-up meeting
we could take a look at that sure um but
but let's just get the answer the
question is it a 5 or 10% effect in
which case it's all irrelevant because
all this stuff is only accurate to that
amount well a factor of 5 effect I think
on certain nutrients who can really
drastically depend I know for instance
like most vitamins and minerals we
consume or especially vitamins we
consume that come from natural sources
are much more effectively absorbed by
our body except for I think vitamin E
where the synthetic version is actually
absorbed at almost twice the rate or
something like that so I think it really
can have significant molecules on way
over there different forms of the
molecule so so you know the molecules
really these are really especially
vitamins or big organic molecules so it
might be that one side of that molecule
fits in to a certain part but the other
is that because of the because of
stereochemistry what that but I think
they might even I think you know when we
say like vitamin E there's actually like
five different compounds that can
technically be considered vitamin E
because to be a vitamin is essentially
our body can absorb it and use it in
metabolic pathways not necessarily
stating it's one particular molecule
didn't know that okay I think it depends
on the presence of also things like what
do you eat visit right right yes okay
but so it isn't I mean like vitamin A
being retinoic acid or something
whatever it's supposed to be that that I
mean that that's not know that is that I
mean that's not that complicated
molecule though did I miss remember that
completely no I think that's right but I
think that it also depends sometimes
like you know will actually not consume
the vitamin will consume like a
precursor and then our body can maybe
some of them are different because I
mean like ascorbic acid for vitamin C is
also not that complicated right right
right
um okay let's take a look here
oh well oh yeah yeah
this is a lot of stuff
but we're recycling most of the parts so
if you okay with the order in the sports
show up there then more or less I mean I
you know more or less but there's more
that this can be tightened up it is a
wonderful thing and you know a huge
amount of work has been put into it so
let's not I gotta see the coming soon
but it's a desert you know yeah I hate
these input interpretations I gotta tell
you something let's let's look at the
alternatives okay it's just so computer
istic ingredients by
what the hell does that mean that
they're all oscillating at it
well frequencies probably a bad term
maybe by count is more maybe by I don't
even know a better word to use but was
it frequently they show up if you take
all the ingredients of all the foods
that match the query so all white breads
in this case and you flatten out all the
ingredient lists MA and then you do
tally on it basically I would say common
ingredients Tomlin greens sure
and then you anyway said common
allergens there
which would probably map from this yes
but I think the common also is referring
to the fact that it's in most of the uh
most of the foods that that are nicely
included so it's a little technical and
boy yeah well then you could say
frequently occurring allergens yeah
that's that's a good name I like that
you
when you're saying 44% maybe if you
don't know but we didn't find counter
examples yeah so in that top one for
wheat-free 44% of Lenoir wheat-free and
then the remaining ones we don't have
any information on but we know half of
them are not suited to vegetarian
because there are non-vegetarian things
is that very interesting okay well what
I would do first comment is use dot dots
or something instead of the actual gray
line here because it will make it
clearer that there's something missing
there and presumably you have a
situation in which there are yes as
there are nose and there're don't knows
all right this is a keen they didn't K
right so I'm suggesting the gray be a
dotted thing or something um dashed
maybe because it's been no no I agree
it's got a spam I'm just - - - - - I
don't you know um yeah I mean I think
this has got to say blah blah blah
unknown and I also wouldn't if this is
both nose and yes sirs are definitively
there I wouldn't gravy yes I mean in
other words it's like you gotta pay
attention if you're a vegetarian you
have pay attention there are ones of
these that aren't vegetarian but but
like this ones like if there's a amount
of yes the nests so it did they know
always is more important for people oh
you know what I mean like yeah I
understand it's not symmetric which one
is the know here if it even though it
appears to the right well we're gonna
have to figure out okay yeah there's a
reason why that's still in dev mode
it still has some work to be done to it
you can these are just to show an
example of some of the data we have for
ingredient substitutions we haven't come
up with a plot design for them yet but
it's just something you can do in
language right now cool
oh boy shouldn't we consider a print
form for intervals with with quantities
yes let's do it involved let's try and
invent one yep
by the way you missed the discussion
yesterday about numbers with uncertainty
in print forms I think you'll like what
we came up with
um approximate cooking time Association
it's like like you know it's it's a it's
a it's a you know professional society
of people never mind
I understand I just think it's it's a
yeah it's not okay
this is very what's that a CTA
a CTA otherwise known as okay um great
well there's a lot of
perfect stuff here okay let's schedule
another meeting I mean we've got several
uncertainties here can we next time have
a yeah I mean the agenda should focus on
some of these uncertain pieces and
inventory and what the different cases
are if we can get this within the next
you know sometime next week it'd be good
so we haven't completed so I at least
haven't completely forgotten all of this
it's really exciting it's really nice um
how good is the linguistics - I think
you've addressed that a little bit here
I mean
much of his pragmatic linguistics how
much of it is hand curated linguistics
and do it complicated it's a very tricky
question certainly a lot of it has been
done programmatically but there's also a
lot of it that's been done by curation
as well III don't think I can give you
any hard concrete two big things one is
basically the current path where as you
saw even if you didn't like it we take
it apart and try to understand
everything and then there are the brain
foods that we might want to pass as one
whole yeah without understanding the
detailed meaning of it yeah we don't
necessarily know it's the secret for
whatever right um very cool the letter
one is the positive milk okay all right
let's pick this up again in a few days
um it's really nice and thanks to folks
on the livestream thanks to you guys and
see all soon